all right yep it's a picture framed
right all right okay no that's fine
all right I'm going to start by
confessing that Africa has always been a
particularly difficult subject for me to
think about but I've been thinking about
it a great deal because of this chapter
humans originated in Africa we have a
consensus on that modern humans Homo
sapiens sapiens originated in Africa we
would consensus on that the populations
of modern humans that departed from
Africa whether to the Western Hemisphere
of the eastern hemisphere created
civilizations for things that we call
civilizations not necessarily not
necessarily agreeing on what the
definition is but in the in the human
homeland that does not that does not
develop Egypt is near but it really
isn't the same thing as Ethiopia or
Somalia or Kenya or wherever we think of
as the homeland of humans in a talk a
lecture I gave earlier I suggested an
approach to thinking about emergence of
civilization that conceived of it less
as a step forward than as a solution to
problems of
shortage of space and resulting conflict
that came about in certain specific
areas at certain specific times looking
at that one could say well should
civilization be seen as something that
human groups descend into rather than
that they rise into assuming of course
that at the onset of the those things we
think of as the hallmarks of
civilization no one was capable of
anticipating what civilization would
lead to as opposed to to not having a
civilization it is quite clear that
agriculture is a hallmark of
civilization but it is not a defining
hallmark that is to say there are many
societies in the world that develop
agriculture that do not develop the sort
of social stratification division of
labour development of cities etc etc
that we associate with the word
civilization there was a time when this
was kind of glossed over I recall
reading an article long ago that said
that the difference between grain
growers and potato or yam or sweet
potato growers the grain growers had to
had to work hard you know follow the
calendar know when to plant and when to
reap and so forth whereas for all those
other people who weren't growing grain
food was just kind of a found thing they
just dug in the ground and there was
some food McMahon from heaven and they
didn't develop the habits of labour or
the customer viewing the heavens for
indicators of seasonal change and so
forth and this was at a time when the
notion that agriculture should be
distinguished very strongly from veggie
culture that agriculture came from Latin
Agoura meaning a field whereas veggie
culture implied that you were having
roots or rhizomes or other sorts of
crops that did not have plowing or did
not have field agriculture in the same
sense of a field corn was always a
problematic item here because it's a
grain but it wasn't planted in plowed
fields so in any case the the notion
that there's some sort of equation
between agriculture and civilization
doesn't hold up the people who argue
that agriculture makes it possible to
have a denser population are certainly
true or certainly accurate on the other
hand agriculture I would say the
artificial planting and harvesting of
domestic strains of plants it doesn't
seem to have universally produced you
know the sort of population stress that
is associated with in this sort of
formulation of things with wheat and
barley this is surprising because wheat
and barley on a calories per acre basis
are nowhere near as nutritional as
potatoes or
maize or beans or things like that so
that if it's a matter of domestic plants
producing more food and therefore
enabling a larger population it isn't
among the grain growers that you would
expect that to be to be most manifest
okay but grain growing has this
ambiguous association with your
civilization it's not it's necessary but
it is not a sufficient cause
another thing that appears to be
associated with with civilization is
property in classic European political
science works property is almost a
defining characteristic of civilization
that the first person who says you know
the produce of that apple tree is mine
yeah I own it and now you have to
exchange a barter for it is sort of the
prototype of the origin of property
property actually shows up first not
surprisingly in terms of you know
objects and you can see a
differentiation in objects that show up
in burials and so forth even among
certain foraging communities so that one
of the most successful non agricultural
not hurting non hurting societies that
we know of were the Native Americans and
the Pacific Northwest where they had
much larger settlements than was common
among foragers in other parts of the
world because of the abundance of the
fish resources that they had and they
had a practice known as a potlatch
whereby the status of a person was was
symbolized by his giving away property
invite everyone to a feast and then over
feed them and then give them gifts when
they leave and then you know send a
servant after them to give them more
gifts I mean it's extravagant generosity
becomes a hallmark and that generosity
is primarily in in objects the notion of
property in terms of of land it's very
difficult for me to see when that began
but I think it's rather late for one
thing there was an awful lot of land
when you think of world population of
the entire globe having a population of
a few million people the notion that
land what could be a limited resource
would only occur in areas where there
were physical constraints on
unavailability of land like a river
valley running through a desert or a
coastal settlements such as you had in
the desert of Peru and northern Chile
but otherwise land was was abundant and
the notion of ownership of land is
rather abstract how after all do you do
you think of ownership of land can you
sell it well then you have to have a
market what would a market mean before
the invention of money now after all we
had domestic crops growing for Oh Flo
seven eight thousand years before before
money appears not very clear what a
market would be in terms of land in the
earliest stages of things on the other
hand there is one thing that can and
almost certainly was owned and that and
that was livestock land was simply there
and you could plant a crop you could
harvest the crop maybe some stronger
person comes along and steals most of
your heart of your harvest but on a
day-in day-out basis the land is not
going anyplace whereas your goat is
somebody has to see to the animals I
know at least one society and the Sahara
Desert where boy boys and girls would be
given a goat at the age of four and then
an additional goat every year so by the
time they got to marriage bull age
everyone in the society had a little
flock of animals so they to take care of
you start at four cuz at four you were
old enough to chase your goat and keep
it from running away and make sure it
got fed and so forth and so on so
domestic animals I don't want get a
little process how domestication came
about but the best ik animals seem to to
me very likely to have been the first
the first property in a non in a aside
from simply objects like jewelry or a
piece of clothing or a weapon or
something of that sort
the first property that demanded
attention
the this is supported linguistically so
that in in Latin the word for money is
Pecunia this is derived from the word
pekus which means sheep in arabic the
word for her well his mouth goes back to
a word meaning sheep the notion of
capital you know capital a and latin a
which meant wealth in ancient Rome comes
from word capita meaning a head goes
back to an indo-european root complet
that means head well what it is what
sort of a head well it's a head of
cattle you know you count animals by
heads you don't count corn or potatoes
by heads tomatoes maybe the eyes I don't
know but but the thing is as you go from
society of society and you look at the
concept of wealth the concept of wealth
is associated more with animals
particularly domestic animals than it is
with with land
I can't think offhand of a general word
for wealth or for property that is
derived from a root relating to to an
expanse of of land interestingly when
the Arabs had to invent a word for for
capital in the modern sense they
he came up with wrassle now meaning the
head of the of the sheep and you know
where asses head so capital is whenever
because rats amalia so if you look at
Africa that remember that's what I'm
trying to talk about here one of the
questions to ask is where are the
animals for the northern part of Africa
we have you know herds and herds flocks
and flocks lots of animals their sheep
their goats their cattle donkeys there's
a long bibliography of things relating
to the domestication of animals in the
Sahara Desert prior to the drying up
that began in 5000 BC and in areas
farther to the north and connections of
those regions with the Middle East but
as you go south of the Sahara first you
hit a belt from Senegal across to
Somalia and Kenya where you have lots of
animals where you're hurting people's
very often peoples who assert dominance
in an area then you go south of that and
into Equatorial Africa which is
presumably where the humans originated
and you say well what animals you have
there and the answer of course that you
have five animals so what about domestic
animals property in in Equatorial Africa
in the areas south of the of the
region the Sahel region that flanks the
Sahara to the south this is a an area
with abundant food with lots of water
and indeed with lots and lots of animals
but they are domestic by large so what
about domestic species there uh are
there pigs there you know and you'll
find that when you get there Equatorial
Africa there are some pigs very very few
in some areas pigs are esteemed as pets
but not eaten in Gabon for example in
certain parts of it so but you have you
have small numbers of pigs here and
there in Equatorial Africa and they are
usually described as being like like
feral dogs in other words they're feral
pigs for the most part they are not
owned in herds this is not a European
Pig culture where you have a flock of
pigs you drive out into the forest to
eat acorns and then smoke the hams when
winter comes
there's no winter but but rather you you
have some pigs and it's very unclear how
long the pigs have been there whether
they are fairly recent introductions or
whether they have been there for a long
time the standard book on the history of
the domesticated animals of Africa is
very non-committal on the other question
of where these pigs came from but we
know there were lots of pigs in the Nile
Valley Egypt had pigs but so they could
have simply come down from Egypt it's
hard to know things don't walk very far
so
unlikely the leis just went exploring
and ended up in the Congo so then you
think well what other animals I have
well they have goats dwarf goats almost
all of the goats south of the Sahel zone
are belonged to a whole variety of
domestic breeds and they're all dwarfed
and my dwarf we're talking about goats
at the shoulder are oh but yay hi No mmm
maybe like that 50 centimeters so
they're something like half the size of
the goats that you have farther to the
north they have short legs the body is
about the same size the torso but they
have a short length so that some of the
goats the stomach almost brushes the
ground they are widespread and there is
no consensus as to where in the world
these dwarf goats came from because we
don't have any dwarf goats at least not
any notable ancestors up in northern
Africa or in Egypt or in the Middle East
or other places it's assumes of the
goats must have come from someplace and
got into Africa and developed dwarfism
dwarfism is a very unusual development
you can induce dwarfism in captive
breeding we have obviously video chair
dogs of different kinds
but as a natural evolutionary
development dwarfism is associated most
strongly with islands and is associated
with a lack of food island populations
if they are small animals when they live
on islands like rats or rabbits they
grow bigger and if they're big animals
like ponies or or pigs or goats they
grow smaller and it all has to do with
the quantity of resources
well Africa had no limit on the
abundance of resources there are
certainly things for goats to eat so one
of the possibilities that is entertained
is that there are dwarf goats because
the people thought dwarf goats were kind
of cool and that they selected for dwarf
goats that they weren't selected that
you know some of them will drink milk
but milk drinking once you get south of
the sahel area was pretty much unknown
but my large if it looks as though the
development of domestic animals once you
get down into the Sahel area and farther
south had a lot more to do with
selecting animals that you wanted for
some reason other than other than just
basic consumption for example the the
animals in the Sahel area clearly have
been picked to have piebald coloration
so that camels everywhere else and
donkeys everywhere else are of a single
color and you get down to Mali or need
air and the animals are black and white
splotched or brown and white swatched
because people thought that was neat
they developed a really interesting
variety of horn shapes that was
considered
the most distinctive features of
domestic animals so that these goats
these dwarf goats they may be alike and
that they are all how all have short
legs but they have really interesting
and diverse and twisty horns because
that was sort of a neat thing to do
there doesn't appear to be any place
that had big herds of goats and it
doesn't appear as though they were
treated as property in the sense of of
the herd animal property that underlies
the arabic notion of sheep or the latin
notion of sheep as sources of words for
money or for wealth so part of the
question then is does property develop
in areas that do not have that do not
have the the extensive development of
animal herding that you have in the old
world so do you have property for
example in north and south america in
the pre-columbian period do you have
property and Aboriginal Australia or is
property something that that is
particular to the part of the world that
developed extensive herding of domestic
animals I would point out the
interesting phrase that we have you know
when you have someone's estate on the
one on the one hand you have real estate
which is land property on the other hand
goods and chattels those are these
that's the other part of a person's
estate well the goods are the objects
you know the you know the havel in China
and the glassware and the furniture and
so forth those are your goods the
clothes in the closet but what are the
channels and where does this work
comfort well not surprisingly this is
the word cattle comes from the same the
same background through French and the
channels consisted of that property that
was antler that was animate as opposed
to real estate which is inanimate and
immovable and goods which are inanimate
and moveable the animate property does
these were your channels so that
consisted of two things your animals and
your chattel slaves so that slaves and
animals become linked together as a
portion of a person's property so now if
you look at North and South America in
particular and comparison with Africa to
the degree that you find that there is
something that that appears to be
property in the in the centuries for
which we have so little concrete data it
appears to be channel's property in
humans people owned or had slaves slaves
could be exchanged so that when we use
slavery as the theme for talking about
African history in the
no from the well really from antiquity
onward it may be that it is not simply
the imposition of a European demand-side
obsession with with this sort of human
trafficking but it may also reflect a
peculiar importance given to to humans
as possessions in parts of the world
that did not have domestic animals and
we're in parts of the world where where
real property where real estate was not
that important because real estate was
was abundant and so far as we know in
many of that most areas collectively
farmed rather than owned with very
specific property boundaries an argument
can also be made that the the state
originates when people who have animals
impose themselves upon people who are
growing who are growing plants there's
some work being done right now by a
student here on the question of why in
the world that ploughing ever originated
if all of North and South America and
South East Asia and Africa south of the
Sahara fed themselves perfectly well
without plowing why in the world did
anyone ever in the plow when you could
simply take a sharp stick and poke a
hole in the ground or take a hole and
drag it along and you have a furrow and
the argument of course is that if you
have a plough you can have greater
production because the animal is doing
the work and it's pulling pulling your
sharp stick through the soil and you get
more production for the amount of labour
that's that expended although in fact
the oxen don't walk any faster than
person could have walked pulling a whole
behind him to dig a furrow but the
questions we investigated is who owns
the cattle who owned the oxen because in
order to have oxen for plowing you need
herds of animals if you're going to plow
up large areas of land you need lots of
oxygen an oxen need to be taken care of
and it may be that the owners of the
oxen invented the plow and then said you
know use our plow or we'll kill you and
then and you can use our plow but you
have to lease our oxen to pull the plow
and in return we'll take half of your
crop this may sound far-fetched except
that right down to the 20th century in
certain parts the world around what I
know of best
landlords ordinarily would take a
portion of the crop every year in return
for having provided the animals that the
peasants use to plow the ground
it's a provision of animals is not a
it's not obvious or a free good when you
go back to two ancient times all right
in the non Imperial parts of North and
South America that say the non Aztec non
Incan parts and in Africa and Australia
you seem to have had populations that
are more or less stable demographically
that subsist by a combination of growing
plants and gaining livelihood from the
from the environment hunting fishing
gathering and so forth in other words
the idea that there is a
a sharp boundary between hunting and
gathering in the one hand and farming
the other hand it really doesn't apply
to very large parts of the world you get
an amalgam you have people who are doing
some farming of what we would call
farming and who were doing some hunting
doing some fishing gathering products
and producing stable populations that
are at least demographically stable
populations and they're not producing
civilizations now this was very
troubling
- or very difficult for Europeans I
think - to understand when Europeans
encountered these populations directly
after Columbus and the new world but
slightly before that in in sub-saharan
Africa and somewhat after that in
Australia and Southeast Asia Europeans
were coming out of a they saw the world
through lenses that put enormous
priority on concepts like property state
and religion it's not the oldie things
but just to pick three fairly obvious
ones you know when we read our classic
works in CC we read about property state
and religion and it was natural that
Europeans when they got someplace they
would want to know what religion do
these people have what is the structure
of their state and you know can I buy
you know some real estate you know it's
that these are simply the things that
people look through the lens hurting was
almost
almost disappeared from the from the
analytical mentality of Europeans once
you get into the you know post post 1480
period it's rather curious at the very
end of crime and punishment when the
protagonist is off in prison in you know
deep in Russia he looks across the river
and sees nomads and I thought that that
was the alternative the idyllic notion
of the nomads but nobody else seems to
see it that way so full three hundred
not really but so the Europeans tend to
ignore or to fear pastoral nomads I say
fear because the legacy of the Mongol
era was long lasting and it was simply a
reinforcement of fears of nomads that
had gone back to earlier times as well
and often warranted fears so they now
they were getting to parts of the world
that didn't have the religion the state
and the property structures or outlook
but they were expecting and in fact that
they used almost to define the nature of
humanity and they didn't have the
pastoral nomadism that they tended to
disdain but they nevertheless recognized
as being a kind of civilization so they
had a very hard time understanding what
it was they were seeing and they tended
to see it see these societies in terms
of deficiencies now either what they
lacked or how they had something in such
a weird and perverted fashion that one
could not take it seriously
to get back into the mentality of this
way of looking at these parts of the
world particularly sub-saharan Africa I
decided to go back to a reference book
rich and 100 years ago only a hundred
years ago namely the 11th edition of the
encyclopdia Britannica comes out in
1911 and I picked the article on Nigeria
to see how did Europeans using are you
English people english-speaking people
using the most important reference work
of the time how did they learn something
about Nigeria at the beginning of the
20th century
you know before a decolonization before
the popularization of anthropological
theories before the before pretty much
anything was known about these areas
beyond a few tales told by earlier
travelers and adventurers now as it
turned out the article on Nigeria in the
11th edition which I could be a
britannica was written by a woman named
flora louisa shaw flora louisa shaw was
among the most famous international
newspaper reporters of her era she
traveled to alaska for the gold rush she
traveled to Australia as she traveled
all over the place
initially writing under the name F Shaw
to conceal the fact that she is a woman
but she was she was an eminently
distinguished international
correspondent foreign correspondent by
the time you get to the to the 1890s she
claimed the word Nigeria before that it
was known as the Royal Niger Company
lands or something like that and she
wrote something it maybe argue and said
you know to continue calling it the
Royal Niger company this and that this
is very awkward and some people saying
we should call this central Sudan but no
let's call it Nigeria and so she coined
the word Nigeria and now we have a
country that that we call Nigeria so she
was not I mean this is the halt is the
reason you when you look for the
viewpoints of a hundred years ago this
is the reason you go to the 11th edition
of the Britannica
so last edition of the Britannica in
which all the articles are signed by
notable scholars or notable figures so
you when you go back there you're not
looking at simply some sort of paid
editor who's updating the entry on
Madonna but rather nothing new to say
but but you're looking at someone who
who was respected as an authority at
that time so you're getting something a
lieu of the official intellectual view
of the time but flora Louisa Shaw in
1902 married a man named Frederick Lou
guard who became the governor-general of
Nigeria and after that she's known as
lady Lou guard and he's one of the most
important people in in British colonial
administration for his services in
different parts of the British Empire
when she married him he was governor of
Hong Kong and indeed the two of them
together you know pushed for the
creation of the University of Hong Kong
they are the Lu guards governorship is
when the university is created these
were very active and dynamic dedicated
colonialists who thought that they were
you know if
doing the Lord's work they were
certainly doing the Queen's work which
was somewhat more important Frederic Lu
guard was a man of his background was in
the military he had served in various
military roles before becoming a
colonial administrator and let's say he
was not the brains of the family and
indeed his reputation largely was shaped
for many years after that like what his
wife wrote about his policies which
weren't actually his policies but it was
what she wrote about him he said the
typical African is a happy thriftless
excitable person lacking a self-control
discipline and foresight naturally
courageous and naturally courteous
impolite full of personal vanity with
little sense of veracity in brief the
virtues and defects of this race type
are those of attractive children all
right no big surprise later you know
really you know I'm gutter level racism
from from as we understand it now but
also it doesn't tell you very much the
idea of that white European
administrators look down on on the
African Negroes there's no more
surprising or and no more revelatory
than the the idea of that American slave
owners look down on the slaves on their
plantations so it you really need to
look at what flora lady Lou guard wrote
to see a more interesting portrayal of
who these Africans were so this from her
from the section of the article on
Nigeria that she wrote entitled
inhabitants she lists a number of tribes
using the word tribe she notes that at
the time she's writing
she estimates the population of Nigeria
at 15 million and the number of
Europeans at 1,000 civil servant
soldiers traders or missionaries as say
official personnel plus plus everyone
else so we're talking about a time when
there was virtually no European physical
presence
there even though they had long had a
trading presence along the coast says
you know first referring to tribes in
southern Nigeria says all these tribes
are fetish worshipers though Christian
and Muslim missionaries have made
numerous converts the ethics a coasts
tribe which has come into contact with
white men have adopted several European
customs and educated ethics are employed
in government service the great secret
society called egg BOE is an ethic
institution each tribe has a different
juju and each speaks a separate language
or dialect the most widely diffused
tongues being ebo and ethic which have
become which been reduced to writing in
general little clothing is worn but none
of the tribes go absolutely nude in
color the majority are dark chocolate
others are cold black parentheses a tent
much admired by the natives themselves
close parentheses or dark yellow Brown
cannibalism human sacrifice and other
revolting practices common to the tribes
are gradually being stamped out under
British control trial by ordeal and
domestic slavery are still among the
recognized institutions in northern
Nigeria northern parts of Nigeria the
inhabits inhabitance are more of mixed
blood the Negro sub stratum having been
to a great extent driven out by the
northern races or the car of the
continent she goes on to talk about the
house and the Fulani who are the great
herding societies of the north and the
house
very much an urban society though she
doesn't mention the major house of
cities in general the people living in
the river valleys have been unaffected
by Moslem propaganda either in blood or
religion thus along the banks of the
Niger Benway and other streams it
happens the inhabitants are Negro and
pagans and generally of a purely savage
though often rather fine type of these
the Munchie who inhabit the district
nearest the junction has been away with
the Niger were long noted for their
intractability and hostility to
strangers whom they attacked with
poisoned arrows via Occam's their
neighbors were cannibals nearer Yolo
lived the bus's who also had a bad
reputation
these tribes under British influence are
turning to trade and agriculture and
agricultural pursuits in the central
hilly region of kochia are other pagan
tribes they wear no clothes and their
bodies are covered with hair unlike hers
south of the been away near the Treiber
confluence 12 the savage and warlike
botos bosses and other tribes in the
districts of e lauren and boar go west
of the niger the inhabitants are also
Negroes and pagan would have a more
advanced type than the tribes of the
river valleys all right this was
compared with with her husband's notion
o the Africans simply childlike this is
more reflective of what passed as an
ethnographic sensibility you know a
hundred years ago
only a hundred years ago we have tribes
the tribes are are distinguished by how
naked they are by what sort of a fetish
of mi worship or if they're of the finer
type they might be affected by by Islam
and you know essentially this is the
sort of thing that we now completely
deplore when we look back at the the era
of of colonialism you don't get things
in quite this extremely fashion if you
are dealing with India because there you
have your tribes your peoples your
castes but you can talk about their
occupations you know that none of these
people are making anything
none of them are selling anything any
then we're growing anything they're just
there with their their juju and their
fetish and their secret society and
their their nude beaches and whatever
all right now the curious thing is that
Africa had such an incredibly profound
impact on the European imagination
and very much through this kind of
writing you know very few Europeans went
there you know there were Europeans who
went to South Africa temperate temperate
country where they could buy property
set up farms bring in livestock and have
a yeren European type society in South
Africa or what's now Zimbabwe or they
went to Kenya where in the highland
areas they had they could have a ranches
and a more temperate stuff but in
Equatorial Africa the number of
Europeans was was incredibly small the
way Europeans knew about this area was
filtered through through communicators
who
we're not creating Orientalist fantasies
in order to to facilitate domination
because the domination was was there no
you didn't need to to create these
things as fantasies in order to convince
the Europeans that this was an area that
they could dominate because the
Orientalist fantasies were designed
primarily for societies that were
civilized urban productive full of goods
and full of goods that the Europeans
actually wanted to buy whether they were
you know ivory boxes from Damascus or
cotton prints from India or tea from
from Ceylon or woodcuts from Japan the
Orientalism that I talked about was
really designed to to diminish people
who were potentially seen as cultural
competitors or as cultural superiors and
who had in the past arguably and not
even the distant past been indeed
cultural superiors you go back to the
period before the Renaissance there's no
question of the inferiority of European
culture compared with India or China or
Japan of the Middle East and it's a
difference it's gradually made up but
Orientalism was devised and in this
negative construction of Orientalism as
a hammer to to drive in the the lesson
that the superficial you know
attractiveness of the cities and the
products and the the romantic costumes
and so forth of the East are truly
inferior to to what Europe has and they
didn't have to do that for africa the
assumption of inferiority was already
there
this doesn't mean that's not Orientalist
but it isn't
or analysts with the same instrumental
impact of the Orientalism that you would
have referring to the Middle East or
China or India or Japan the same thing
would apply to the Aborigines in
Australia there was no need to to you
know to prove that they were culturally
inferior that was taken as an assumption
so very few Europeans were were
communicating and yet the image of
Africa becomes overwhelming you take a
word like fetish she says that all these
tribes have fetishes the amount of ink
that is then spilled by Europeans
thinking about fetishes is absolutely
extraordinary and I'm not talking here
about you know you know sucking your
boyfriend's toes or something like that
I'm not talking about sexual fetishism
I'm talking about the idea of a fetish
as a type of of contact with with the
natural world is it religion or is it
not religion yeah it turns out that that
you know generation after generation
you get European thinkers who are who
are chewing on that issue what is the
relationship of fetishism what is
fetishism how does it relate to to
religion you know is a fetish was an
object presume to be an object it was an
object that had mysterious power of some
sort
was it worshipped well maybe not was it
used for magic well yeah maybe it was
but not always maybe not then related to
it came in the word totem was a fetish
so then people wrote endlessly on the
question of totemism and how it relate
to fetishism totem which originates as a
North American Indian word referring to
two - sibling relations and marriage
limits that was mistranslated by a
European that the the original the word
doesn't mean a symbolic you know being
to whom a person or a tribe is related
but it makes no difference where the
word the word comes from but the idea is
if in totemism which you have
particularly in in the americas
particularly North America and in
Australia there's the idea that either
groups or individuals have a particular
connection now conceived of in various
ways to some sort of natural object
either an animal or a plant or a
physical feature of some sort in one
breakdown of this the one by Claude
lvi-strauss he says you know it can
really take four forms you can have a
group that relates to a category of
animals for example our tribe is
descended from the porcupine or it can
be a group related to a single animal
our tribe descends from you know the
great porcupine you know one particular
porcupine or could be an individual who
relates to a category of animals saying
you know I have taken the porcupine or
the porcupine has has taken me as part
of its
clam or it can be an individual relating
to a individual animal in one in one
scenario with a child you put an animal
on its chest and then you conceive of it
as gradually melting through the chest
and becoming Lea internalized so that
person is now coterminous with that
animal which you know we can do that now
with you know with good filming and show
something entering the chest usually
it's going the other direction
so the endless notions of you know is
the totem is the fetish the locus of a
god more often you know the ethnographer
is sort of define it as a sort of a
friend or companion relationship maybe
is it is it demonic well sometimes you
get it portrayed that way but not not
usually but the concern over what were
the spiritual feelings of these of these
people in Africa and Australia and how
they relate to parallel feelings in the
Americas particularly outside the great
civilizations and remnants in say
Central Asia or remote parts of India
people began to think that they were
looking at a sort of primordial stratum
in human existence so some of them would
say well you start with fetishism and
then you go to polytheism and then you
go to monotheism and then you you
finally rise to Unitarianism or
something like that I mean some people
really literally try to portray this as
part of a that as you went back into
Africa or Australia or actually going
into the past and seeing the the primal
days of humanity but there was no
agreement on what this what this would
mean and but it became a sort of a motif
that could be picked up and transferred
to other fields such as sexuality of the
notion of fetishism who or - buying
cheap consumer goods with the Marxist
notion of of commodity fetishism where
you you say that you know buying a
buying and using an iPod is is a
deliberate capitalist distraction to
keep you from overthrowing the the
existing order which is true yes
so so Africa and Australia but and North
America some degree but particularly
Africa becomes this source of thought
the source of of of images I think for
this reason
when you get to art hum and Picasso and
you have the big canvas lady Mazel Tov
annual where you see some of these
chubby ladies of in sort of cubist
construction with faces that are
designed to look like African masks when
people first saw that they thought this
is the most extraordinary thing we've we
brought this this africanist into our
art putting a Japanese motif in which
you can find in the Impressionists is
now something that we can trace back to
in our history and say oh yes we can see
where where this costume or this design
comes from from Japanese woodcuts but it
didn't have a shocking impact in the way
that Picasso's African masks did because
it was primitive to a primitive though
became very ambiguous because primitive
also meant self-taught and so primitive
art was was a word that comes to be used
but savage is another word that that
gets used to be the idea that that you
had a vast array of different sorts of
african images and so it didn't really
strike people in particular so picasso
showed an african masks on a on a cubist
european head and people said that is
africa whereas now you go to any museum
and you go to the african art section
and you see that the variety and
sophistication of african art is is vast
and that there are some
some schools of African art that are
hyper-realistic
that isn't all abstraction the famous
spending bronzes for example so then you
have the idea that well this is also
affecting music and you'll have savagery
and music the you know the impact of
Africa on Europe may be greater than the
impact of Europe on on Africa the
Europeans aside from the areas I
mentioned aren't very numerous they by
and large avoid educating local people
or training them to do European things
because that's expensive and because
they didn't see what the financial
returns would be they did try to convert
them to to Christianity with sort of
mixed Mis mixed success so some areas
become heavily Christianized but on the
whole by the time you get to to the 20th
century
sub-saharan Africa has not yet been
impacted in the way that let's say India
has been impacted by by the British or
areas like Java where you've had the
introduction of coffee plantations or
Malaya where you have the introduction
of rubber plantations most of Africa
does not develop a plantation economy
the economic value of Africa is is
modest until you find
Gold in South Africa and then diamonds
well but the riches of the ores of
Africa particularly the Katanga province
of Congo weren't really realized very
early because that's an inland area and
getting inland in Africa was but was
slow the number of Europeans around was
very very small so so if you look at the
question of relation of of Europe to
Africa and and Australia let's say the
looking through the lens of a hundred
years ago when you're interested in
things like property and state and
religion all you see is sort of a a
blankness and the people who saw
something else were not the people who
went there Freud did not go off to some
undeveloped land to think about totemism
some of the the anthropologists did the
anthropologists went places but it was a
very very pronounced impact some of it
had a genuine ethnographic substance to
a substance to it for example if when
lady Lou guard mentions the what does
she call it here
the great secret society called egg Bo
okay egg Bo also known as echo pay this
was a indeed a secret society it was one
of a myriad of social structuring
institutions in a genuine generous
region that existed alongside kingdoms
although kingdoms don't appear to have
been all that numerous Lord blue guard
for example created what he called
warrant chieftains so that he would have
somebody to negotiate with and he would
pick people who were influential and say
okay you are the chieftain now and some
of them then claimed that they were in
aristocracy of some sort but this was
rather artificial where something like
the egg bow society which was not the
only one represented structures of
organization that were not very apparent
to two people who were accustomed to
estate somewhat similar to the ways in
which Sufi Brotherhood's were not very
apparent and the nature of their
structure and whether they were they
were good or bad in the case of the egg
Bo you have a hierarchy it was someone
like someone like freemasons I suppose
where males belonged there were several
different orders of of rank you could
rise in rank which you did through
paying money but also you then gained
money from being of a higher rank they
developed a system of writing
we think in CBT there are hundreds of of
symbols that show up in in egg Bo
contexts that have been recognized as
being video grams in other words you can
say well that you know if you a symbol
that's a symbol for a woman or the word
woman that's a symbol for a man I think
marriage is yes something like that
so whether you know how old this is I
mean tracing back these in CBD signs
some people go back say that they go
back to the first Oh maybe 400 AD
something like that they're not simply a
response to to contact with with the
Arabic or the Latin alphabet maybe they
were similar to some of the earliest
signs that you had in the in the new
world but this was a an important social
structure that you had in Nigeria and
then it carries over into Cuba so that
in Cuba the egg bow
become the Abba quoi well they have a
similar set of structures similar
beliefs remains a secret society still
exists and it was long thought of
thought of as being somehow derivative
from from Catholicism or some Western
tradition or else a carryover from the
native-american inhabitants of Cuba from
the period of Columbus but now generally
is agreed that this is a an import from
from West Africa that still exists and
it then becomes very much associated
with with certain musical traditions in
Cuba and cultural traditions so
increasingly I think there's you know
the scholarly community in particular
became more and more absorbed with the
idea of what places like sub-saharan
Africa and Australia represented in
terms of the nature of humanity and by
contrast had relatively little interest
in things like economic development once
it turned out that Africa was not an
enormous ly wealthy wealthy place and
yet when all this studying was done and
there this long history of anthropology
of ethnography of psychology of
religious studies trying to understand
the nature of African societies or of
Aboriginal society or North American
native societies
when it had also hadn't done it it still
remained that that this is a matter of
looking at these people as objects and
when post-colonial studies came in I've
talked about last week with the idea
that to look at non-western peoples as
objects and to divide them into
categories or you know impose upon them
certain structural understandings that
they themselves would it necessarily
have come up with the idea in
post-colonial studies came that this
really isn't what we should be doing and
maybe we should go back and deconstruct
and question all of the studies that
were done over the last hundred and
fifty years and see whether they were
not only right or wrong maybe that's not
recoverable but whether they were
basically morally justifiable the the
imposition of a notion of cast upon
India to the degree that that's
associated with British imperialism
there or the structuring of native
relations in Algeria as being between
Berbers and Arabs even though the
Berbers and Arabs didn't see things that
way these had consequences in the same
way in Africa the definition of
boundaries and so on had consequences
but I think that what you have with
Africa and Australia and the Americas is
is more profound in terms of its effect
upon euro-american mentality than what
you have for India China Japan
in the Middle East now in the United
States we may say this is a particular
concern because of our own history of
slavery and the fact that we have a
population and a very substantial
African heritage but when you look at
European culture and the impact of this
primitive or savage or you know primal
human force that they'd rather
arbitrarily astride to these to these
areas you see that the impact on Europe
was at least as great and probably
greater than on the United States in
some particular respects so at the very
beginning of this week I was talking
about how I knew a economic historian
the last generation who believed that
was worthwhile to draw up a balance
sheet you know no colonialism was it
good or bad for country X and you you
measure the investment you measure the
output you measure the the benefits the
drawbacks and you've come up with some
sort of balance sheet which he found
basically positive now what I'm
suggesting here is that there's another
kind of balance sheet that you can you
can look at which has to do more with
the impact upon the the imagination and
the psyche of of regions and that's what
I say you know it's if it possibly
Africa had more impact upon Europe and
America than they have had upon Africa
you